Hey so I'm going to talk about the
nutrients involved in Hashimoto's
Hashimoto's is an autoimmune condition
of the thyroid your thyroids located
right in the base of the neck and you
develop antibodies that's basically
attacking the thyroid keeping it
inflamed
and usually that stems from some type of
a stress event could be emotional stress
or physical stress that then lowers your
immune system making you susceptible to
developing this condition okay so there
are four main nutrients that I would
recommend number one selenium you know
everyone's talking about iodine and yes
you need iodine from sea kelp that's
very very important but selenium is just
as important as iodine it's a trace
mineral and it helps in the conversion
of t4 to t3 it's also involved in making
what's called glutathione which is
involved in the immune system in
detoxification so there's another thing
I'm not going to give you the blog name
for it but it's NAC that converts to
glutathione it might not be even a bad
thing to get as a supplement NAC and
glutathione to actually reduce
inflammation to improve the thyroid so
it's not a bad thing to add if you
really want a comprehensive thing but
it's quite a few things to look at but
selenium is very very important selenium
is also really vital in liver function
and also detoxification then we have
vitamin D vitamin D is usually always
low in Hashimoto's and why because
vitamin D is essential to keep your
immune system working and without
vitamin D it's the immune system just
doesn't function and then we have
vitamin A which a lot of people don't
talk about vitamin A is also important
with the immune system and it allows t3
to function vitamin A is usually always
low with Hashimoto's but I'm not talking
about consuming bunch of carrots that
would be the pre vitamin A it has to be
what's called retinol or the active form
of vitamin A so these two vitamin D and
vitamin A are fat soluble and you can
probably get them just from getting
colorful oil gets virgin cod liver oil
and that way they have a nice balance so
that would be really good
take as well just to combine those to
kill two birds with one stone touristy
and then we have magnesium magnesium
also helps in the conversion of t4 to t3
and t4 is the inactive version and t3 is
the active version of the thyroid
hormone so these are the key nutrients
that I would recommend if you have this
condition but remember you know there
could be a situation where you're not
converting because the gallbladder is
not working or your liver is
dysfunctional because it takes your
liver to convert t4 to t3 and good
healthy kidneys as well so that's just
something else that I always look at if
you're trying to get your thyroid to
work a little bit better awesome last
point is estrogen when estrogen is very
very high in the body if your estrogen
dominant and that could also interfere
with our function alright so thanks so
much for watching and leave your
comments below presip okay just let me
do that over here press the subscribe
button press just press this button
right here subscribe okay that one right
there just do it right now hey if you're
enjoying my videos press the subscribe
button below and I will keep you updated
on the future events thank you so much